now zooming out again as you write
don knuth has called attention to a
breed of people
who derive great aesthetic
pleasure from contemplating the
structure of computational processes
so don calls these folks geeks and you
write that you remember
the moment you realized you were such a
person you were shown the
hungarian algorithm to solve the
assignment problem
right so perhaps you can explain what
the assignment problem is and what
the hungarian algorithm is so
in the assignment problem you have
n boys and in girls and
you are given the desirability
of uh or the cost of matching
the ith boy with the jth girl for all i
and j you're given a matrix of numbers
and you want to find
the one-to-one matching
of the boys with the girls such that the
sum of the associated costs will be
minimized
so the the best way to match the boys
with the girls or
men with jobs or any two sets
um now any possible matching is possible
or
yeah all one-to-one correspondences are
permissible if there is a connection
that is not allowed
then you can think of it as having an
infinite cost
so um what you do is
uh to depend on
the observation that
the identity of the optimal
assignment or as we call it the optimal
permutation
is not changed if you subtract
a constant from any row or column of the
matrix
you can see that the comparison between
the different assignments is not changed
by that
because you're penal if you decrease a
particular row
all the elements of a row by some
constant
all solutions decrease by the cost of
that
by an amount equal to that constant
so the idea of the algorithm is to start
with a matrix of
non-negative numbers and
keep subtracting from rows or from
our entire columns um
in such a way that you subtract the same
constant from all the elements of that
row or column
uh while maintaining the property that
um uh all the elements are non-negative
simple yeah and so and so
um what you have to do
is is find
small moves which will decrease the
total cost
while subtracting constants from rows
or columns and there's a particular way
of doing that by computing the kind of
shortest path through the elements in
the matrix
and you just keep going in this way
until you finally get a full permutation
of zeros while the matrix is
non-negative and then you know that that
has to be the cheapest
is that as um simple as it sounds
so the the shortest path of the matrix
part
yeah the simplicity lies in how you find
the what you i oversimplified slightly
what you
you you will end up subtracting a
constant from some rows
or columns and adding the same constant
back to other rows and columns
so as not to not to reduce any of the
zero elements
you leave them unchanged
um each individual step
modifies us several rows and columns by
the same amount
but overall decreases the cost so
there's something about
that elegance that made you go aha this
is a beautiful
like it's it's uh it's amazing that
something like this
something so simple can solve a problem
like this yeah it's really cool
if i had mechanical ability i would
probably like to do
woodworking or other activities where
you sort of
shape something
into something beautiful and orderly
and there's something about the orderly
systematic nature of uh
that iterative algorithm that is
pleasing to me
you